[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
taco
tuesday
right after raid mar-a-lago monday
hunter biden's laptop this morning be
like
i don't even own a safe
oh
oh what a great week for america
what a great week for america
the the right-wing media machine is
absolutely freaking
the [ __ ] out and it should tell you
something it should really tell you
something
every time they do this every time
they're in full freakout mode it does
not go well for them that's why they're
in full freakout mode you even have
kevin kevin mccarthy giving more
more gifts to pro-democracy people out
there to win elections by saying if we
we win elections we're gonna do what
we're accusing them of doing all night
last night
all night all night on right wing media
fox news uh tucker carlson couldn't even
show up because his britches were so
shitty probably
all night
they complained hunter vines laptop the
email lady her emails
they complained that this was a
political witch-hunt it's a political
prosecution
what is this communist russia which they
would love this to be communist russia
the point though
is that they are calling for exactly
what they're saying this is have you
noticed that they're like well this is
this is egregious this is way
way over way too much overreach from the
government
joe baden
but what they want to do is take over
the government and they want to
prosecute anyone and everyone who's in
sight
anyone and anyone who's in sight you're
a democrat jail [ __ ]
it really they are projecting here
and they have no other option but to
project here now i'm gonna get to the
raid but the response of the raid is way
more important folks we know trump's a
criminal
i mean jesus christ minus dutch put it
best
in their tweet when your main question
is what [ __ ] crime are they waiting
for
when that's the main question you're in
deep deep [ __ ] [ __ ]
but let me tell you something the raid
in and of itself is another animal but
the response is what is so important
okay because we're talking about
politics right we're talking about how
to win elections
and the reason why the republican party
the domestic terrorists that they are
they've self-proclaimed this i'm not
making this [ __ ] up now they have
self-proclaimed that they're domestic
terrorists
i'm not committing libel they said it at
their nazi rally in texas the nuremberg
rally that they just held they declared
themselves all domestic
every single one of them
the domestic terrorists
are freaking out and digging in their
heels
because of elections and because of
politics
that's why if if they were really smart
about this and by smart i mean
want to have a chance to win elections
in the future
if they thought their party had a future
they would take this opportunity to
absolutely [ __ ] dunk trump in the
[ __ ] trash can
absolutely take out the [ __ ] garbage
get rid of trump for good
just cut him off that's what they would
do in this moment
but they're not worried about the future
of their party because they know there
isn't a future of their party there
isn't one
they have they have scraped the bottom
of the barrel
so much in this country
that it's all they have left now that's
it that's all they have left the tail
that does wag the fascist dog
that is the gqp
the former republican party now the
party of raids fbi raids
and they have to defend this stuff even
marjorie taylor green last night was
wanting to defund the police along with
many others
remember remember back in 2020 when
democrats were against the rule of law
and they weren't they were against law
and order when they wanted to defund the
police which no democrats said that [ __ ]
no democrat said that [ __ ]
there was no policy there was no bill
to defund the police i mean maybe there
should be i i guess you could argue that
but there was no bill
there was no legislation there was no
person in in any legislative body
meaningful legislative body in this
country
who was trying to defund the police but
here they are
the minute their mango mussolini jesus
gets raided for crimes that he's
committed
defund the police
and the reason why they're freaking out
mostly is because they're scared they're
next
they're scared they're next they're so
happy that the news is that this has to
do with the classified documents
marjorie taylor green
roger stone some of these others alex
jones alex rogers stone was on alex
jones show last night talking about this
by the way
by the way
tony why is alex jones and roger stone
relevant in the story because um there
was a back channel during january 6
between the people who controlled the
qrf the oath keeper stewart rhodes
the guns and weapons
and the president of the united states
and there's a couple people who have his
private phone or who talked to him on a
on a frequent basis speaking of that did
you see the news that got buried alex
jones and tucker carlson tweet or text
each other every single day
i guess there's dick pics between tucker
carlson and alex jones i mean i don't
know if they're dick pics i don't know
just saying they text back and forth
intimately just like him and roger stone
apparently trade
nude photos of their wives anyways i
digress i'm getting off track here
oh what an exciting morning what an
exciting morning it is
dan bongino goes on fox news last night
on jesse water show and says liberals in
this country the left think this is
funny everyone thinks it's funny
actually bongino
everyone who isn't a trump sycophant
everyone who doesn't alter at the at the
altar of cheeto dust anyone who doesn't
put on their knee pads and give that
[ __ ] fat nasty slob fellatio thinks
this is funny
all of them
every single one of them
and i'm actually grateful in this
country
that we have in our democracy
that we can actually have a system of
government that we the people choose our
representatives and those
representatives as long as we do our job
as citizens
and do our civic duty and actually have
some common sense about electing
officials and make sure
that if we put a party in power not just
people but a party in power like we have
now the democrats in the house the
senate and the executive branch that
they are responsible enough to handle
that power
and they did just that with the january
6 select committee which they were
forced to do by the party that is not
responsible
and kevin mccarthy says as soon as i'm
speaker of the house i'm gonna
investigate everybody
everybody
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
he's just giving you
he's just giving you what you need to go
out and engage in the ballot i always
talk about it here
i always talk about it to actually get
to the point where you want your
democracy to be you have to engage in
democracy you have to actually do the
thing of democracy you have to do that
thing
and it's not just voting it's not just
marking who you want to be your
representative that's not all it is
you have to engage you have to talk to
people
you have to help them get information
that they don't already have
so they can make their decision your
community members the people at your
church the people at your work the
people at your children's school at the
pta meetings
jesus the people at the checkout line at
the store
those are the people that you have to
engage with we have we have to engage in
our democracy
for far too long americans have taken
advantage that democracy will be there
tomorrow all i have to do is wake up no
it is hard work to keep a democracy
especially when you have fascists at the
front door
and we
we
we witnessed last night
after
donald trump was rated for what we are
assuming
are documents classified documents
that's what we're assuming at this point
now there's a lot of speculation and i'm
gonna speculate a lot
that's what i'm gonna do
today but there's a lot of speculation
around why they went there
that in and of itself is a problem for
the republican party and trump
but here's the
thing you have a responsibility here
forget about the raid forget about trump
forget about the republican party at
this moment you have a responsibility to
your way of life your democracy to do
the thing that you need to do
and engage in your government it's yours
we are the government we
we get to [ __ ] decide it is our
choice no matter what some bonehead says
it's not your body not your choice some
[ __ ] trumped up white dude
we still have the choice of voting
we still have the power of voting still
so use it while you have it and it's not
just marking your ballot it's engaging
in democracy it's having that strategic
outrage it's making sure that your
family members and your friends know how
important this is
because after last night we
we know now
that the fascists are willing
are willing to sell our democracy down
the river just for political power
because that's exactly what they're
accusing merrick garland of doing
this is really [ __ ] stupid now our
our title today is dark garland raids
trump
right and of course uh it did you know
the dark brand and dark garland stuff
it's all a [ __ ] joke
it's all it's all to mock these dumb
sons of [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about these people who wear
these trumped-up costumes and they fly
to flags and you know the people who
showed up at mar-a-lago
last night
at palm beach
as if palm beach wants a bunch of
redneck hillbillies crossing the bridge
from west palm beach to [ __ ] be
flying trump flags and acting like a
bunch of goddamn rednecks
no they do not
they do not and trust me the people in
palm beach that live over on the island
in palm beach
[ __ ] hate trump and hate trump
supporters at this point especially if
they set up camp there which i hope they
do
i hope i hope his supporters set up
[ __ ] camp in front of that [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] hotel
and just make it look trashy as [ __ ] as
trashy as trash can get [ __ ] yes let's
do that let's really show the world who
this [ __ ] is
and who his [ __ ] supporters are some
people are trying to fear monger on on
mainstream media about the dark web
and all the dangerous all the dangerous
stuff that's going on over there well
they're watching them
that's the point they know where they're
at now they know where they're at and
they're watching them
folks they're going to start rounding up
all the real domestic terrorists the
people who are wanting to commit
violence and planning to commit violence
you're going to watch as they round them
up
it's going to start happening they did
it when obama was present when they were
plotting to kill obama they were
rounding them up and rounding them up
and rounding up all over the country
and they're gonna do the same here
because they're watching they're paying
attention now let's get let's get to the
raid itself
because i'm dying to talk about the raid
itself
i'm dying to talk about the raid itself
so
the raid itself
there's a couple different things here
donald trump did not know about this
raid
and neither did his staff or people
around him that is very significant
that's very significant
and it's very significant because
it would be hard to keep um anyone
inside this investigation that you're
assuming is going on now at the doj he's
under a criminal investigation
now now we know i mean there's big huge
confirmation right there in front of
your face that he's under criminal
investigation there wouldn't be an fbi
search
warrant like that
without there being a criminal
investigation that we know
but it would be very hard to keep the
word from leaking out with a lot of fbi
agents that we're going to have to go
and actually
execute this search warrant the other
thing you have to remember is the state
of florida or the local law enforcement
officials probably were called in to
help execute this warrant you know
traffic
get get all the agents in get all the
agents out
so ron desantis probably knew about this
ron desantis probably knew about this
yep
and donald trump did not the other thing
that i think is significant about the
raid
is that donald trump was in new york
when this happened so he wasn't actually
at mar-a-lago when this happened which
is very very important to really mind
[ __ ] him
if the department of justice is really
looking to screw with donald trump here
and get him to do all kinds of crimes to
cover up more crimes because i think
that's what's happening here you know i
i don't know for sure exactly with these
documents and how many and what they
took in the 15 boxes
but there seems to be
um this cat cow cat and mouse game
between the department of justice and
trump to see how much crime he's
actually going to commit
that's my take on it
because they waited until he was in new
york
they didn't let this leak which means
they kept this under the uh most
scrutiny of raps that you could possibly
have
they have a magistrate a federal
magistrate
giving the the illegal authority for
this search warrant which that's another
thing
um that i think is very significant here
is that it is a search warrant
it's not uh so they searched his
residence at mar-a-lago
and and he even brought up in his little
statement
that they cr they they broke into his
safe well they can search it safe
they can search is safe why can't they
it it it makes me wonder
about the safe because i really was
thinking about it this morning i'm
thinking you know what donald trump if
he is as rich as he says he is he could
really afford a really nice seat
and now bear with me bear with me i'm
not saying he bought a very expensive
save i'm saying that that cheap
[ __ ] probably brought a like
like a walmart style safe you know like
a costco style safe and that's what he's
get he's that's what he's got all this
crime hidden in
right and all his fake jewelry and his
fake cufflinks
and he's got all that you know the the
fake ass jewelry that looks expensive
he's got it in his cheap ass [ __ ]
safe
in a closet somewhere probably probably
doesn't even screw to the ground i'm
sure
my thought was well
would they have a safe cracker
on scene with the fbi to break into the
safe
because if that's the case then they
knew there was a safe there they knew it
they knew there was a safe hmm
and he brought up the safe now this is
the this [ __ ] idiot always projects
he's always projecting he's always
giving you the evidence he's always
doing it
every single time and by him bringing up
the safe in the actual statement
and knowing that the fbi would have to
bring someone who could crack a safe or
the tools to crack a safe
on site
because otherwise they just take the
[ __ ] safe
i mean why wouldn't the fbi just take
the [ __ ] safe
i mean yeah the safe isn't evidence but
everything inside of it
so they knew something was in that safe
they suspected something was in that
safe
so what could be in the safe i don't
know and that's that's the tell in his
statement that there was something he
was hiding in the safe that's why he
said it
that's why he said it
someone tweeted out last night that they
should get donald trump on tv and do a
two-hour interview with him over the
phone and just let him talk
just let him talk on open air and i
thought that's a hell of an idea this
guy will tell us every single [ __ ]
crime he's committed
after after he's had his staff go
through all his secret places his secret
places
to try to figure out what they took and
what they didn't take that's the other
thing that's beautiful about this
and really
really really really getting underneath
the skin
of donald trump
really getting underneath the skin of
donald trump
is that he wasn't there to figure out
what the hell they were taking and to
say no keep your hands off that no don't
touch that that has nothing to do no
collusion no corruption no collusion no
corruption no collusion it was a perfect
phone call it was a perfect phone call
it was a perfect phone call
oh boy
yeah we do think it's funny dan bongino
we think it's great what a great week
for america last tuesday
the citizens of kansas told kansas to
[ __ ] off you will not take our rights
away from us you [ __ ]
you will not do that
we will keep our rights and we will keep
fighting for our rights in the state of
kansas
the tide is turning and then this week
we watch as the cheeto dust mobster
the mango mussolini jesus
grandpa poopy pants himself donald j
j trump
fall to an fbi search warrant what
a fantastic
a fantastic
week i i got some news for you for
today's show today we're going to have
texas paul on
um he's having trouble with his link
that's right it's tuesday texas paul is
back with us
we also we also are going to try to
bring in rachel bittikoffer at the top
of the next hour
we missed her yesterday she was out of
service
but today we're going to try to bring
her back on so we have texas paul the
midas mighty favorite
he was going to come talk about texas
stuff but i'm sure with this news we're
not gonna get the much that's in texas
we're gonna have florida talk
on texas tuesday almost the entire the
entirety of wild texas paul is here
and then rachel bittikoffer is going to
join us at the top of the other i really
really wanted to talk to rachel about
the nuremberg rally on on over the
weekend the nazi rally down in texas
cpac
i really wanted to talk to rachel about
that but god this topic
whoosh you talk about being gown long
gone gone like the wind gone
cpac is that news has sailed
with this news that we have this morning
um again great great news for not just
not just
not just the people who are against
trump because you got to remember
that this is about democracy this is
about law and order this is about
the decisions that we make
every single day not just during an
election or on an election day this is
about the decisions that you make every
single day when you're out there
engaging with people talking to people
when they say things like oh both sides
are the same when they're not
they're not
we only have one party in our two-party
system unfortunately right now and what
i mean by that
is that the republican party
has failed this country and its citizens
by being for democracy
being for democracy first
and then having their ideology second
they are not pro-democracy they want to
destroy our democracy and they proved it
to us last night
in their total [ __ ] freak out as
their orange mussolini jesus
gets raided
he wasn't arrested he wasn't charged but
they're terrified of what's to come
absolutely terrified of what's to come
not one democrat was freaking out i
didn't see any of them freaking out i
mean you besides andrew cuomo
but that that guy's got cause to be he's
got reason to be concerned about fbi
raids himself
why are we still listening to andrew
cuomo i have no idea i have no idea i'm
not really sure
i don't know
either cuomo for that matter
but i'll tell you
that it's up to you
it is up to you pro-democracy person
for you to engage
in your government because it's yours we
are the government it is
us and the beautiful part about what
happened last night is we made the
decision to put responsible people in
charge who would decide who the attorney
general is to make those responsible
decisions
and that is the most important thing
that we can do
is to make sure that civic minded
responsible pro-democracy people
are in charge of our
government it's us
because
he stole
our documents
he stole stuff that belonged
to us folks when he took those boxes and
i don't know what he did with it i don't
know if he sold it i don't know if he
gave it away i don't know if he's lying
about having it and trying to hide it
i don't know
but there is something to trigger this
raid with for a hundred fbi agents to go
down to mar-a-lago
and to kick down his [ __ ] door and
open his safe
and it has something to do with those
documents and maybe they found some more
stuff for some more crimes but when your
main question is what crimes are they
waiting for
that's the question
so let's not re let's not forget let's
remember that it is us it is our
government it is our office of the
presidency
and he [ __ ]
on us he [ __ ] on our government he [ __ ]
on our vote he [ __ ] on our office
he [ __ ] on our democracy and he
continues to do it
and the total freak out from the right
wing last night was more evidence that
they are willing to keep him in power
and to keep [ __ ] on our democracy
and it is your choice
yours
rather you are going to let them do that
or not
we see we see sea changes in texas ohio
pennsylvania georgia arizona
we're watching as the tide is turning
and the fraud is being exposed
that trumpism is somehow popular in this
country that is all [ __ ]
all of it it has been for a long time
he's not popular
trumpism the american people do not want
it
eight million more people voted against
trumpism
because i don't believe 81 million
people voted for joe biden
i believe it a lot of those 81 million
voted against trumpism and i believe
they still will
but we have to we have to be very clear
about how important it is
for them not to gain power and they're
telling us why folks they're saying it
out loud
so join me
every single weekday monday through
friday right here
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page don't go anywhere you are
not
do not go anywhere as soon as we get
back we have texas paul
right after this break do not go
anywhere texas ball right after this
stick around
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the tony michaels podcast thanks for
sticking around through the break
oh baby
i can feel it out there i can feel
democracy growing
i can feel people loving democracy more
and more every single minute of the day
i got a special guest for everyone here
everyone uh we missed him last week
because he was he was cancun paul last
week let's let's face it he was cancun
paul last week he was down in mexico um
not not because he was running away from
anything because he he deserved a
vacation he had earned a vacation but he
is back in texas he is back with us here
on the tony michaels podcast for texas
tuesdays with texas paul but i'm sure
we're gonna have to talk a little bit
about florida so he might end up being
florida ball this morning texas paul
good morning how are you
top of the morning to you sir i'm
wonderful i am wonderful well i i tell
you what a lot a lot of people are
excited about some of the news um that
has happened just over the last 24 hours
um you know a lot of people had been
responding to it
it kind of came out of nowhere no one
really saw it coming when i actually
noticed it on twitter there was a small
reporter um that was from south florida
and they were like um there's a big raid
over at mar-a-lago all the big reporters
need to be on this fast and i was like
holy [ __ ] it was like two minutes in
and then i got cued in that yesterday's
confirmed by donald trump and he was uh
posting about it over on fraud social um
and it it it's an amazing uh turn of
events it's an amazing piece of american
history that we will remember forever um
and i and i say that because
this is you know a lot of the right
wingers are frustrated because this
hasn't happened in our country yet and
paul the reason why it hasn't happened
is because we haven't had such a [ __ ]
criminal that was inside the white house
that is and you know i i wanted you know
i was watching what they were saying and
you know trying to think through what
the what their freakout was about
but really honestly their entire
argument here is you can't do this to a
former president well you don't do this
to former presidents because former
presidents aren't [ __ ] criminals like
donald trump as a criminal what
says you
you know you you're you're knocking it
out of the park there tony i'd
have been so disgusted by the rhetoric
coming out of the right you know if if a
guy will
pick up an ar-15 and go to comet ping
pong pizza because he read some q and on
[ __ ] about you know
some conspiracy theory
the stuff that's being said right now
is going to drive these gravy seals and
and
ar-15 tote and right-wing idiots to do
something violent
it's insane what's going on right now
in the right-wing
bubble it's just insane it is really
uh you know you just
you can't believe some of the rhetoric
you've got paul gosar calling for the
fbi to be uh
to be dissolved you've got uh anthony
sabatini rep anthony sabatini he's
saying that the
state of florida should break ties with
the doj
and that any fbi agent acting in a law
enforcement capacity
in the state of florida that doesn't
have the approval of the state of
florida to do what he's doing should be
arrested immediately
i mean
that sounds like to me
that sounds like to me that it's um
that it's more
um they're really terrified of what
could actually become of the doj our
co-host gabe sanchez is joining us now
um here's the thing
is if you look at what happens with like
a federal warrant right and then when
law enforcement decides to go and
actually
execute a warrant with a hundred fbi
agents
they normally go to i don't know like a
state agency like a highway patrol or
state police and then they go to local
law enforcement because what they
understand is that there's going to be a
lot of vehicles there's going to be a
lot of things happening in that one
little space so they need uh you know
some law enforcement
you know to protect um the agents from
you know people passing by people who
want to come [ __ ] with them or media
they just want control of that area
so ron desantis likely knew about this
raid now maybe maybe only hours before
but here's the thing that's so important
about this that i think people should
understand
that this is a serious [ __ ] deal this
just wasn't something that they [ __ ] out
and then went went over there and
executed a raid this has been planning
for a while now we watched as those 15
boxes were toted off the property and
hauled into a u-haul truck up to back to
washington and i don't know if that's
the actual reason it is reported that
that is the reason um but i have a
feeling that that either some of those
classified documents or some of that
stuff that he took from our government
from our white house from our office of
the presidency they're ours it's our
stuff um it's the government stuff and
we're the government
i believe that some of that stuff did
not make its way back to washington and
that's what they are looking for so
there's a lot of speculation out there
and there's going to be more and more
and more
but but what do you guys think do you
guys did you guys think that he kept
these doc that's something like there
was some of this stuff in the safe or do
you think he sold some of this [ __ ] i
mean i wouldn't put it past him what do
you guys think
i mean i i wouldn't i wouldn't put past
trump to uh
just to take something with the intent
of selling it we already know the guy's
broke right so he's trying to figure out
who the highest bidder is whether that's
on some sort of black market some legal
selling or whatever it might be i also
think that yeah he probably kept it
because he's got some weird like oh i
just want a momento of like this moment
of me being in office
you know until the point that someone
goes i'll give you this much money for
and he goes well i don't need it
actually
well i mean i mean he hangs all this
crazy [ __ ] on the wall right right right
and i would you know like eric trump was
on sean hannity and he was like oh they
went into the safe and there was nothing
in the safe right okay i highly doubt
that i guarantee there was something in
the safe and yeah to your point earlier
like i do think that
and let's be clear here there wasn't
these boxes of of information these 15
boxes
they didn't just accidentally show up
like oops we put on the moving truck and
it just happened to come over it wasn't
like you left something at your last
airbnb and was like oh can you can you
send it back to me it was intent there
was malicious intent in taking those
things and they're like yeah we're going
to take it and if they ask for it then
we'll deal with it then but i think when
they you know when they got back to 15
boxes they probably went through and
they're like
not everything's here or
they're like we've got everything
but now we've discovered there's other
things that weren't on the list that are
now missing or also missing
so paul i want to talk about this safe
for a second because
i i i kept running to my brain last
night i'm like you know he claims to be
a billionaire he's not really as rich as
he says he is but a guy this guy is rich
enough to have a decent safe but i
almost bet that this thing's a piece of
[ __ ] right it's like a costco style save
yeah i mean i mean come on it's it's
trump he's tacky as [ __ ] paul what do
you think what do you think it's a nice
saver
you know i
i'll be honest with you it's probably
the original safe that was at mar-a-lago
when he bought the place to be honest
with you it's probably a 1912 edition
uh you know
box piece of [ __ ] i don't think he he's
much into
spending real money on things like
decent safes that just i don't get that
feeling from the guy and you know
gabe i think you're absolutely on to
something there
the fbi doesn't do a raid like this
willy-nilly
they really don't there's political
fallout from this there will be violence
over this
they know it yeah they they they
had
a more nefarious
uh
something going on that made them do
this because you know they've gone down
there and gotten documents before
this this was not
kosher you remember the january 6
committee when we were all on the panel
talking about stephanie grisham
and we kept hearing from all of the
people we'd go to coverage afterwards
during our round table and listen to
people and they would always say there
is more out there there is
very very damning
information out there and i think this
is part of it because you know stephanie
grisham gave testimony under oath that
she saw trump destroying
uh classified documents that she saw him
stuffing them in his pocket and leaving
with them that she saw him when they
were leaving the white house boxing up
uh
these documents and taking them
so no i don't think this is just uh hey
give us our documents back there's
something much more nefarious to this
that he was up to to warrant
dozens of fbi agents to do and tony you
are dead on the money that's going to be
the great part in watching this
uh remember i said liz cheney was going
to burn this [ __ ] house down
and go piss on the smoldering ashes
you hit it on the head with desantis
fbi agents dozens of fbi agents and
armored vehicles do not just roll down
the street and show up at your house
because people call the cops over right
right and the cops have to know
they have to be involved desantis knew
this he green lighted it he kept his
mouth shut and he threw his greatest
political opponent in 2024
under the bus
pulled the back tires on him hit the
brakes and stand on the gas until there
was nothing but a pile of meat left of
trump i guarantee you
he road
you bring up a good point which is like
when we're talking about who like we
haven't even announced who's running in
2024 right we're still dealing with the
the upcoming 2022 midterms but everyone
right now on fox and other right-wing
shows are saying oh you know it's
biden's way pulling his opponent out
trump
you know tony and i talked about this
last night which was
neither candidate has been announced
so in both those ways
no one is running for president in 2024
so there are no opponents there are no
candidates that are doing it now the
closest thing to a candidate that is an
opponent to trump would be desantis so
no one is talking about really what's
happening here is desantis is removing
his own opponent from the race so again
yeah
he knew full well had to approve it sign
off and you know it is funny to see all
these people who are like oh no knock
warrants they're not a big thing with
like people like brianna taylor who are
victims of those but then for this stuff
they're like oh well
this was
they just came unannounced and they were
dressed up like normal people
and they they didn't have fbi jackets on
so we couldn't point them out it's like
cry me a [ __ ] river you know that
that goes back to their full freakout on
um on fox news and others because it is
this low light calling for violence type
stuff
where they're like oh there's going to
be hell to pay and you know oh this
country's going to be pissed and there's
going to be people in this country that
are willing to fight for you know
trump and blah blah blah and on and on
but but um last night the images from
palm beach and i don't know i i went to
uh look at palm beach um palm beach is
like an island right like on the side of
west palm beach and it's kind of like
you know all the rich people live in
palm beach and all the non-rich people
live over the bridge in west palm beach
right and and last night you watched
west palm beach trump trump humping
idiots come across the bridge and just
piss off just piss off all the rich folk
oh you know you know they're like what
in the actual [ __ ] circus is going on
here well it's i mean it's straight up i
mean it's nimby right it's not in my
backyard right these are the people who
are rich and they're like
don't come over the bridge guys guys
right this is these are the people that
sued trump
for living at mar-a-lago right they do
not well and because they don't want us
they don't want his supporters there
that's the reason why exactly
and and that's that's and and you know
um i forget who it was but even even on
the mainstream media they're kind of
stoking fear by saying all the dark web
and the deep dark parts of the web are
are activated now tonight and all this
[ __ ] and i'm like well
any part of the any part of the
interwebs was activated last night with
this news which is a good deal and
really honestly by them yelling and
screaming and projecting their
authoritarian ways in last night and
today and on on for the next few weeks
it'll be clear to this country why you
don't want them in power right like
because they're they're saying we're
gonna do the thing that we're accusing
you of doing as soon as we get power
like well if it's so bad why are you
saying that's what you're going to do as
retaliation like what the [ __ ] well they
want you know republicans want vengeance
only if they can be the ones that do it
as opposed to law and order which they
rant and rave about
and then when it comes to actually you
know the fbi following law and order
they go whoa whoa guys
we didn't actually mean it for us we
meant it for the people who are our
enemies our opponents whoever's running
for office that
uh has done nothing wrong
but we've done something wrong we don't
want that spotlight on us you know
that's what calls well paul we've seen
this in the january 6th select hearings
and i want to mention they're supposed
to have more hearings and i know you'll
join us so make sure to follow us here
on the tony michael's podcast on the
youtube channel here and then go over to
the minus touch not yet don't wait till
the show's over but you can go over the
minus touch network and follow us there
because we will be having more and more
of these hearings but this was a theme
in the hearings even where the
republicans are like oh well one one
case for us another case for you type
stuff
absolutely absolutely you're hearing it
all over the right wing it's it's
you've got marjorie taylor green flying
an upside down flag on her twitter page
right now you've got
uh you know these same people that were
screaming lock her up lock her up lock
her up are now going on luring jim
jordan was on laura ingram on fox news
and
talking about how well we're gonna have
the gavel and you're gonna pay for this
i mean literally saying it out loud that
there's going to be political
retribution and that's not what's going
on here folks let's let's be clear about
this christopher wray is a republican
appointed by trump
he's hand-picked him
he is not working with joe biden to get
trump he is not that is not who this man
is
he believes in a separation between the
administration and and and the
fbi that's one of the reasons trump
hated him
was he said no i do not work for you i
work for the attorney general that's it
talk to my boss that's it that's the way
christopher wray works
and
we have a separation of powers that's
working here the judicial branch weighed
in they listened to the probable cause
and they signed off on a warrant
folks
this is the way investigations work and
if we can reach one
[ __ ]
out there who's thinking about doing
something stupid
listen
it's an investigation
if there's something there trump will
have his day in court
he will be able to prove his innocence
if there is nothing there he will walk
right the other thing's so public
the other thing too is i wouldn't be
surprised like if they're if this really
was
uh unfair and unjust trump would have
blasted that search warrant
all over the internet right right like
if this really was a big problem like
and obviously he doesn't want to do that
because that search warrant is going to
clearly indicate why they were there
which was either getting more additional
or like additional classified documents
or you know a specific thing that they
were looking for that's gone missing
which would obviously cause a lot of
people say
wait wait wait why
why did you take that right
but trump doesn't want to do that he's
not willing to show
the evidence to prove
that he is innocent and this was an
unwanted uh raid on his property oh
they're sieging my property oh get the
[ __ ] out of here they came in
full disclosure they they told you why
they were there they had all of the
evidence they clearly couldn't get a
search warrant if they did not get
approval from a judge to say yep this
all makes sense and you have a case here
for why you need to go there it's not
you know ron desantis obviously wants
his whole florida state army to go do
whatever he wants but that's not how the
federal government want works like you
can't just throw someone in and say go
do this right and it's to your point
would you say christopher wray
he is someone who follows you know
justice and democracy and won't just be
some you know pawn or political like you
know pawn for
for someone who's of a a higher power to
just say yeah okay i'll
i'll go raid that place or i'll go do
this or whatever but again tony said it
he was hand picked by trump and all of
these maga people these republicans seem
to forget the concept that comey was
left because he didn't have loyalty
and and rey was put in
as a replacement and it turns out that
he also was pro-justice and
pro-democracy and wouldn't fall into the
loyalty kind of language that trump
wanted
paul what says you
money
right on the money well i i think i
think the um you brought up um the
executive branch and joe biden and who's
picking who and where's where's going
where and i think last night um it
should calm down some of this talk
especially from some of these lefties on
on the internet uh trying to stoke fear
that merrick garland isn't doing his job
that hey because merrick garland also in
this in this search warrant merrick
garland would have signed off on this
this would not you know go
um you know below mirror garden this
would go to the top um there would be he
would make sure that this was airtight
before it was presented and make sure
there was not going to be any kind of
you know shenanigans before it was
presented to the magistrate right like
his it's his department of justice it's
his fbi it would go to the top to make
sure that this was locked tight now the
other thing that goes to that not just
the dark garland dark brandon stuff but
also um last night the white house
claims and and we'll probably find this
out through history because we're not
going to find it out right away but
we'll probably find this out through
history that that the white house did
not actually know
um what
what was going to happen down at that
raid and that only gives more evidence
and and allows um more people to
understand that merrick garland is
acting here it is happening um the
wheels of justice are moving but they
move really really [ __ ] slow
i'm sorry i can't stop laughing though
all i can think about is i know a
kentucky turtle right now that really
wishes merrick garland was on the
supreme court
this was well actually actually i'll
disagree with you there i actually think
mitch mcconnell is one of the happiest
guys in washington today
he's one of the happiest guys oh
absolutely this is
mitch mcconnell is happy because it's
going to take it's going to take away
any chance that kevin mccarthy has to be
the speaker of the house it's going to
take away any chance that donald trump
has to even think about running for
president i mean it really it really is
because mitch mcconnell i believe is
more on the side of liz cheney but
because of his leadership role and how
the tail wags the dog he can't operate
in that space right now he has to wait
for this all this cloud
to roll over until he can operate in
that space again
distinct possibility distinct
possibility right there and i'll tell
you something else that it does is it
ends ron desantis i don't know if you've
looked at the polling but
charlie crist was already closing i mean
the the race was already tight
it was already tight
this is neck and neck i mean because
it's coming out the desantis knew
and the mogan nuts
are not going
they're not the forgiving type they're
not going to say well desantis is our
boy this that the other no they're going
to say he [ __ ] trump he [ __ ] us well
and you know
it could divide the party uh between you
know the the mogalodites the maglidites
part of them could go towards desantis
part of them could go towards trump
which uh we should capitalize on folks
we should politicize every single move
of this because that's the other thing
that i want to get to here paul is
because you're watching in texas as beto
o'rourke is um really coming up the
heels of greg abbott uh by talking about
community talking about texas not
talking about you know crazy whack-a-doo
[ __ ] he's actually talking about [ __ ]
that people care about um and he's he's
giving he's presenting a campaign that a
lot of politicians pro-democracy
politicians in particular that can
follow in this country we have a race in
pennsylvania that is so wide open for
fetterman fetterman's absolutely
absolutely trouncing oz um jd vance who
has got his cheeto dust knee pads on
that will give him more reason why they
should not elect him uh you watch as
herschel walker is the the trump you
know anointed um brainless candidate in
georgia so warnock is likely to win that
race which could pull stacey abrams even
over the finish line so everywhere you
turn everywhere you turn this
is not marco
well right well i mean so everywhere you
turn not just in florida though
everywhere you turn this raid has
massive massive political uh
implications on a lot of races around
the country
and the fbi and the attorney general
knew that
and i think that's where
you know some of this fodder about
merrick garland doj not doing kind of
stuck you know some of it kind of stuck
in the narrative that democrats don't do
anything that they're weak and you know
all this nonsense on and on and on
because it really was all nonsense now
that we see that they're willing to go
raid him just months after they pick up
these 15 boxes right
which i i mean there's probably an
indication that there's a crime inside
the boxes or missing from the boxes but
i guess my point here
is
what does what do you think the
political implications are and how do we
as pro-democracy people politicize this
and take advantage of this to make sure
that we win these races and these morons
don't get a hold of government and do
what they say we're doing which is
politicizing it and and having you know
communist russia and what do we do what
do you think we knew paul
well i tell you
you're you're right on
the point in that we have to drive that
wedge in as deep as we can you know
you've got carrie fake
in arizona who's now
screwed herself
in this mock a civil war in the
republican party
the mccain machine in arizona just using
it as an example of what you're talking
about the mccain machine in arizona
is beloved
it is just beloved uh you know the
daughter not so much
but john mccain
is a
hero to every veteran in arizona and
carrie fake just came out and talked
[ __ ] about john mccain in the mccain
machine and how she has drove
driven pardon me driven a stake into
their heart
folks
that put katie hobbs in the governorship
right there
that attack on mccain on the mccains
which we need to be amplifying puts
katie hobbs the democrat in the
governorship it was a tight race already
and kerry fake commits suicide
desantis is screwed he is screwed he
knew about this he cannot say he didn't
know about it
merrick garland does things by the
numbers we've talked about why the fbi
contacts local pd
desantis is screwed in an already tight
race we have to be
screaming about the split that you have
you've got
maga calling for jim jordan to be
speaker of the house for christ's sake
i'm not even kidding
jim frickin jordan
for speaker of the house
there's nothing more that would win
elections than than floating that jim
jordan is going to be speaker of the
house everyone would go vote against
anyone who would say that type of [ __ ] i
mean again this is this is like you said
drive a wedge in as deep as you can
the the issue that we need to focus on
because i think the rate is important
right and getting the facts of the rate
is important but i think
that what happens politically after the
rate is way more important to us as a
country
that politically is what is going to
dictate how our government is formed in
2022 2024 2026 and 2028 because each one
of those elections as soon as we're done
with 2022 2024 is going to be the most
important election paul and gabe that
that is what is going to happen and we
have to make sure that us as
pro-democracy people because we are the
government are willing to stand and say
we're willing to politicize the [ __ ] out
of this to make sure that our government
is pro-democracy not these [ __ ]
weird-ass
you know looney tune lunatic whack-a-doo
fascist we just don't want it anymore we
want some sanity we want to get back to
doing the things that
our country does like building bridges
and and creating jobs and
advancing technology we want to get back
to that stuff and argue that stuff we
don't want to have to continue this long
slog of you're a fascist you're domestic
terrorist we don't want white christian
nationalism why are you people
undermining our fundamental democracy
why and but we cannot do those other
things until we take care of this
absolute cancer that we have and this
raid is part of it but what we do
politically with the politics beyond the
raid is way more important than that
raid itself it's funny it's hilarious it
feels good that finally something's
happening but after the raid after the
raid and what we do with the politics is
way more important
and it's a chance to clean up our own
damn backyard let me tell you what i did
okay you know i founded the ride or die
democrats and and people were screaming
about merrick garland they really were
they really were
and to keep the ships all sailing in the
same direction i told people i said look
i've got a following of thousands tens
of thousands actually
if you'll come with me
come the end of august
if merrick garland hasn't done anything
i personally will go stand outside the
doj i will go to washington dc and i
will get a bullhorn and i will scream
why are you not acting
to keep people
focused
because i knew i was never going to have
to go
this is the guy that prosecuted if i can
give a shout out to merrick garland and
what what i really knew in that
situation was that
this is the guy that prosecuted timothy
mcveigh
this is not he's got balls like church
bells people
he doesn't leak he is fearless and the
fact that this is a once in our history
moment because we had one president the
first and only president to not engage
in a peaceful transfer of power
that this attorney general and this is
why i said mcconnell may have wanted him
in the supreme court and not as a.g
because another attorney general may not
have had the political
strength
to do what merit garland
merit garland is doing which is actually
setting i mean this is history happening
folks it's never happened before that's
right and he's hitting the stage for
justice is what is happening go ahead
gabe search i was just gonna say it's uh
you know even if it's not mitch
mcconnell that's regretting it i can
guarantee that other republicans are
saying like oh you know in the moment
we got him we forced this candidate
through we put her on the supreme court
you know or like we we screwed him out
during the obama administration and we
forced through the people that we wanted
and i think now they're looking at and
go oh maybe we should not have let
regular garland evolve into dark garland
like
that that was like if there was ever
like a villain origin story that was it
whether he was like okay [ __ ] it i'll
get mine i'm coming for yours too and i
think republicans right now are really
regretting the moment
i think so too
paul one uh one more one more thought i
want from you uh before we go to a break
and because we got to get to another
guest here um one more thought on this
dark garland dark brandon um
are you into these memes i can't stop
looking at these memes
i just can't quit i just
i love them man i love them i love that
they're doing that and you know somebody
had a great suggestion a great
suggestion
joe biden
needs to make a gigantic let's go
brandon banner
and give a speech
about everything that he has just passed
give givea you know i just just
took out
one of the top leaders of
uh
al-qaeda he's just i mean one thing
after another after another after
another and just give that speech in
front of a let's go brandon poster
just to piss these guys off you know
i am loving these dark biden memes they
are the best i mean i i mean have you
seen how many different ones there are
out there oh there's there's there's a
ton of every day they're they keep
making them and making them you know the
the best part is is that this morning on
fox news they're you know they were kind
of they didn't understand what dark
brandon is because a lot of these memes
and stuff
are stuff that the right has made but
now the left is taking it and making it
and just completely different and owning
them like yeah he was he was secretly
getting your ass he secretly was working
behind the scenes as a badass um and and
i think it's it this is more messaging
that the left needs to take up the left
needs to embrace this stuff and the
democrats and pro-democracy people out
there need to put on their their
fighting gloves when it comes to the
ballot when it comes to voting and
engaging in your democracy so paul give
us one more pitch of where and what they
can do to engage in their democracy
folks i am telling you first of all
first of all subscribe here follow the
tony michaels podcast then when this is
over
go to midas media
go to the midas touch youtube page
subscribe
there
we are following these events minute by
minute i i guarantee you right now
there's information coming out from
midas media about this raid they they
are digging into the legal aspects of it
they're digging into the sources of it
you know i've i just did a piece on the
dangerous rhetoric that's editing right
now uh you know
folks we are
not
the the rest of the news media you know
you've got people
hell i turned on msnbc the other just
the other night uh last night for a few
minutes i should say
and they were actually saying that this
was gonna hurt us
[ __ ] how
i mean i could not follow i couldn't
follow that twisted pretzel of logic
you know it's like they can't help
themselves they've got talk [ __ ] about
democrats tourette's
you know just tell it how it is
trump [ __ ] up
he is his ass is in a sling
they don't do these raids until they've
got your nuts in the vice i am telling
you folks
i
am very close
just to some special agents and i'm
telling you folks
they do not make this particular move
until your ass
is grass
i am telling you this is you heard it
i'm making the case part of it this is
the i'm putting your ass in the coffin
and driving in [ __ ] nails
that's when the rage comes
yeah well you heard it you heard it
right here james said like gabe said
they [ __ ] knew what was there
they
knew what they were looking for that's
right well you heard it here folks you
heard it here breaking news texas paul
breaks the news donald trump's nuts are
in a vice thank you texas paul for
joining us i can't wait uh next tuesday
uh come back sir the audience loves you
we all love having you here thank you
texas paul will everyone stick around
we're we're going to have rate dr rachel
bennett offer right after these messages
thanks again paul we'll talk to you very
soon my friend
see ya
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
oh
oh the trump fun commercial
dave it has so many more meanings now i
don't know how how old that commercial
is it's been a while since you made it
but boy boy this morning and last night
they really could use support from the
trump fund they really oh yeah
i guarantee i get well i heard last
night he was already trying to fundraise
off the raid itself so
you know
of course he was why wouldn't he why
wouldn't he play the victim tony i am
the victim i didn't do anything wrong
now give me the monies that's what
they're saying oh man well i want to
bring in one of the greatest political
strategies my favorite political
strategist um
bottom line she's my favorite political
doctor rachel bittikoffer dr rachel
bittikoffer look there's
we got the view of the dog look i
upgraded my view right i look much
better like that
rachel so i want i wanted to so badly
talk to you about the nuremberg rally
yeah that was um that happened over the
weekend but it has totally totally got
excuse the expression here trumped by
the raid down at mar-a-lago um tell us
what your view is of this raid and why
it is so important politically
yeah no i mean i'm with the dude that
was standing in front of the alamo and
being like what
this is not bad for democrats it's not
bad for biden it's not bad for the rule
of law and that's all that really
matters anyway right uh so i i thought
that was funny he's like yeah you got to
talk [ __ ] about democracy talk [ __ ]
about democrats tourette's so this is
huge guys i mean here's where here's two
things number one i think it's
increasingly clear that this is relation
to the national archives case which is
by the way in my opinion one of the most
legally like problematic for the
president the entire reason that the
presidential records act was passed by
congress was because nixon was taking
[ __ ] oh dude
and you know you can't so it's a direct
violation of the letter of the law
but it's actually really a violation of
the entire spirit of the law so um you
know i think that whatever must be in
there
must be extremely damaging there there's
no way that merrick garland and
christopher wray who's a trump appointed
uh fbi head right um would authorize
that a judge would approve so we have
two branches of government involved in
this process
a warrant to search the ex-president's
home unless there was a very compelling
reason and when we find that out i bet
it's going to be a big deal
and not only but you bring up obviously
say you bring up nixon and yesterday
august 8th we've got 48 years to the day
nixon
resigns and then yesterday on august 8th
we've got trump saying that he was
raided so it's like you know again the
connection is they they share many many
similarities whether it's uh roger stone
having nixon's back tattoo and being
trump's advisor
whether it being august 8th was a day
that they both kind of had these big
moments in their time or it was the
presidential uh
uh uh
uh records like preserving the records
you know like in the archives this is
one of those things where it's like
there are so many similarities
either somebody was like yeah we'll do
it on the eighth just because
like if it really was dark garland
saying yeah you can go [ __ ] yourself
trump no it's not any of that i know
here's how we know guys i mean here's
the thing that the wright's going to
really run into trouble trying to argue
the biden administration had any kind of
role in the timing because it could not
have [ __ ] been at worse timing for
joe biden than to have this story break
the news cycle right now should be
dominated by the um democrats momentum
on legislation the credit claiming the
speech that he just gave about the chip
stuff tomorrow's the the burn that um
the burn pits for vets law
uh this is not a week that joe biden
wants to spend talking about donald
trump i say that though joe biden okay
and his team and maybe even democrats
all around the board probably feel like
oh [ __ ] we've just had the rug cut under
us but you know every news cycle that's
about the republican party and their
nefarious criminality is a better news
cycle for us than anything else
so so how do we politicize this because
i think that's the most important thing
because i think so so many times people
say oh democrats don't have messaging
and democrats have messaging they just
failed to organize to to politicize it
so what do we what do we do with this
piece of information because i think the
rate is important but i think what we do
politically with the raid to make sure
these people these lunatics don't get
their hands on government
to to to institute their fascist ways
and we saw that with the cpac the
nuremberg rally in texas and now we're
seeing it with their response to the
raid itself especially the speaker uh
the speaker to be of the house guys like
i i tweeted out about how the media
should not be covering that as if it's
some kind of normal thing that could
happen where a um ascendant speaker to
be of the opposition party for a
completely lawful investigation without
any information without any hesitation
puts out a tweet that could incite
people to political violence that is not
going to happen in a normal democracy
it's a it's one of the symptoms of our
sick sick system and it should not be um
you know glossed over as towards to how
dangerous that kind of behavior from
kevin mccarthy really is
well you know uh
texas paul brought up another point
about ron desantis because everyone's
pointing out that desantis would have
known about this raid even just maybe
hours or days before because he would he
would have been responsible for the
state police and and and making sure
that they helped in that raid and in
that operation
do you think do you think that this
could be damaging politically not just
not just to some of these senate races
but clearly some of these races that are
in florida with marco rubio and ron
desantis being up for election do you
think this puts them on the other side
of this raid it could put them at risk
yeah let me be clear i'm a big fan of
all the speculation about desantis
trying to undermine trump um even though
i think most of it is completely wrong
and i think it's probably wrong here too
um i don't have information about state
police assisting with the raid i know
the
secret service was informed and prepared
to assist at the gates of mar-a-lago but
i i personally did not know that the
state police was there also and i'm kind
of wondering if you know that for sure
and then um number two
you know here's the thing this is a this
the president was taking and hiding
troves of clas top secret documents
right some of these documents are so
secure
in the original report that was um put
out when they seized the the stuff there
are there are interviews inside that
article that talk about
uh documents that are so classified that
they can't even say the topic that it
covers like national security or you
know whatever nuclear armaments like
they can't even tell us the topic of
that we'll never know the topic um we're
not talking about low-grade
classification you could argue
might have been missed like in the
hillary clinton stuff there was very few
files that were improperly coded
remember they were improperly marked and
unclassified and they should be our top
state secrets are clearly classified
donald trump knew exactly what he was
doing and you know i think that we
should be on the attack on national
security what has this man done to to
undermine our geopolitical strength and
i think it's quite a lot and so does
general milly
well also on that point because this law
this president's erection
records act um the only time it's really
been used
in a criminal case is when that
information was transferred to another
individual so do you think that there's
something more nefarious here that it
wasn't just him taking it and giving it
to someone because we know donald trump
is desperate for money at all turns of
his life and everywhere he goes and
anything he says he's always griffin do
you think he could have uh you think
this could we could hear a headline or a
story that he sold some of this
information and that's what this is
about that in those 15 boxes there was
stuff missing i don't know
yes i do think so i mean we're thinking
about we're talking about a man who
tried to overthrow the american
government
245 years of peaceful transfer of power
gone right in an instant and we now know
that he plotted it planned it executed
the insurrection part of it after
everything else fell through for him and
he intentionally tried to siege the
capital right so yeah to me this is this
is a man that would definitely try to
exploit his
you know
access to national secrets for profit
absolutely
well i i i'm i'm on key with that and
and gabe i i know
i know we've talked about it before
when when the original 15 boxes were
taken like how much stuff was left
behind like how much was he trying to
hide when they went to get it right and
i was thinking last night gabe that
what if in the national archives when
they went to get that stuff that there
was fbi agents embedded in that national
archive when those people went down yeah
i mean who knows i mean you know
mar-a-lago is because there's a you know
a former president uh that lives there
like the the the location is a a
high-risk secure high security risk area
right you had the woman
uh who went and took a i think was like
a bag full of electronics and she
earlier this year and she got sentenced
to eight months in prison for taking
those things so like
this is one
it's a huge security risk because it's
not only residential but it's also one
where people can come through
you know as they want and then he also
holds holds events he has people coming
through he takes photos with random
civilians in his office like these areas
are very very accessible to the public
and are a very big risk and that's why
this is such a big deal because
like rachel said there are documents and
other things in there that they can't
even say what it is because even the
idea of letting other people know like
oh a former president walked away
with this specific type of document that
is such a big like whether it's nuclear
codes or it's a location of this or that
or whatever it might be the fact that
they just let a president walk away with
these things
is
is insane and also gives and it i mean
this whole thing makes us look like a
[ __ ] joke to the rest of the world
because we didn't have any sort of
protocol to be like oh no stop you at
the door these things will not leave
right so that's i mean like you've got
photos of people taking out paintings
and there's a you know the lincoln bus
that's being taken outside like where
you know random people taking things
outside of the white house during the
transition
and no one's kind of
doing a check on those things until
after the fact when they're like oh we
actually just didn't audit and we
noticed that these things were missing
and also these documents that should not
have been even given i mean we already
know that trump wouldn't even listen to
the daily briefs he would say someone
else read them and tell them what they
said so i have no idea
i can't even fathom what those documents
could have been uh considering the fact
that the guy can barely read
you're not wrong i mean you know here's
a guy he couldn't take the presidential
daily brief he he literally responded to
north korea at the dining room i had a
national security meeting in the dining
room of mar-a-lago so yes these
documents were a great risk okay
and my assumption is they went down to
recover the 15 and then you know the
things that they really want need to
recover were not included in that and
then they were like hey we need that
stuff too and trump was like no no no
and they finally executed a warrant to
go and seize them so we will find out
those details and in the meantime we're
just going to continue to speculate
right
but to me um
you know the severity of this situation
in terms of our geopolitical alliances
is really bad guys we already know that
our intelligence gathering operations
have been compromised to some extent by
trump's um you know ability to disclose
national secrets without penalty okay
and what this is revealing is that our
system is wholly it was set up in such a
way that it operates basically on honor
code and that is a dumb [ __ ] way to
run a system that involves humans
because humans by their very disposition
are not honorable okay right i mean you
you look you look at everything from
covet and every anything else where it
says like hey i need to take personal
responsibility
for the well-being of those in my
community
most people would say as we've learned
and seen it in real time goes
nah [ __ ] that so if we have those same
those same people because there is a big
thing when it comes to human error right
there's a there's a whole concept
around social engineering which is how
people can easily access information and
data about you without ever having to
actually hack your computer or your
phone or whatever they just ask you
simple questions it's why a lot of
people get uh scammed right because they
are willing to
give one bit of information that leads
to another and so when you have it to
this scale to this big of an impact of
like there are documents and a present
and this guy we already know
was a dumb ass and was doing things kind
of frivolously
it's he's already a big risk in and of
itself so i think that's a that's a big
point that you bring up
yeah and we i mean honestly if they're
going to come back and say at the end of
the day let's let's just let's speculate
okay he's got some really high value
really critical docs in a completely
unsecured manner that he improperly held
back after being requested by the
archives and even like had you know
arranging the deal with them like if you
go let's speculate and say he's done all
of that
and that they had contained these state
secrets right the defense will be
that the president can't
actually violate
declassification because he has the
power to classify everything
what a [ __ ] stupid system okay and
i'm really concerned
like how did our jurisprudence evolve to
create an insulated from criminality
presidency it seems exactly opposite of
what the founders would have intended
and since we pretend to value that so
much right like there is you're never
going to sell me
um on the fact that the the founders
thought hey institutionally let's make
sure that the president is completely
inoculated from the law no
not from people who are afraid of a
tyranny and a king
i agree with you and speaking of tyranny
and a king we watched over the weekend
because i want to get your take on this
before we before we leave you because we
got to get to the [ __ ] list roundup we
got to go through the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends here but i want to get
your take speaking of dictators and and
lawless leaders we watched as hungarian
hitler orban came to texas to the
nuremberg rally and mango mussolini
jesus joined him
at the nuremberg rally but we watched as
the republican party proved that they
want to turn our country into a fascist
state and they're saying it out loud
they are not hiding it and they are not
ashamed of it and i want to get your
take because that is the reason why you
were supposed to come on yesterday you
couldn't connect but i still want to get
your take on the seat back because i
think this we can't lose sight of that
we can't lose sight of what they did we
have to make them own that we cannot let
them forget what they did on the
nuremberg rally on texas over the
weekend yeah and so far tony i haven't
seen a single piece of reporting that
says hey for the first time in american
history one of our two major political
parties not some third party like the
american fun party in the 30s one of our
two major political parties held a
fascist rally on american soil that
elevated and honored an autocratic
fascist dictator from an eastern
european country and so far i have not
yet seen one media report about this i
mean i've seen reports about cpac and
the weird things that were said but
never once that tells people hey over
the weekend the republican party held
what could only be described as the
antecedent to a nuremberg rally and it
was
very disturbing and it was coming from
people like rick scott who heads the r
and uh the republican senatorial
committee he's no low weight he's no
marjorie taylor green or warren bobart
this dude rick scott former two-term
governor of florida and if you listen to
the back end of his speech
he literally taps right into the
goebbels and hitler playbook and and
says literally they're everything in the
system is an organized conspiracy
against conservative republicans the
whole [ __ ] system he said everything
tech hollywood the education system the
government the fbi the bureaucracy right
and that you can go and go and pull some
nazi speeches from the 30s guys i'm
telling you this [ __ ] is about to get
real well the other thing that they did
uh rachel and gabe that was just
absolutely astonishing and they gave the
nugget to absolutely
um every elector election that there is
where it's contested um well and even if
it's not contested they actually defined
themselves out loud on the loudspeaker
and put it up on a big huge jumbotron
and said
we are all domestic terrorists i can't
believe they let that happen rachel
why why is this going to be so hard to
make them own this now that all this
raid stuff is happening and it's going
to get buried but we should so what do
we do to make them own that
yeah tony i'm kind of curious about that
so like they thought they were being
snarky is that i i guess and like nope
it wasn't sabotage is what you're saying
right it was real it was it was it was
them somebody might have gotten into the
but yeah i mean on that side i mean part
of the there's two there's two systems
that are that are leading to political
violence and it's not it's very serious
it's not funny at all it's [ __ ] scary
as [ __ ] dude because those guys are you
know being pumped up to see as a
subhuman that's what they did to the
jews they made the jews less than human
and the poles and then they murdered
them right
so step one make them less than human
and like that entire conference for
three days was designed to do one thing
radicalized the republican party into
seeing almost everybody that's not them
as subhuman and it's extremely
problematic that the media is allowing
this to happen allowing kevin mccarthy
to come out within you know an hour of
of this um search being announced and
attack mayor garland and say basically
hey we take power we're going to witch
hunt you over this legal and i am sure
every [ __ ] dot i was crossed every
team or dotted and every t was crossed
uh search warrant right like we are
we're in really bad spots so i hope
people will start thinking and talking
more about that
well i think i think that's uh fair to
say and i say it every day here and i
continue to pound this drum we have to
participate in our democracy we have to
gauge in our ballot and that doesn't
just mean marking the ballot that means
communicating with our community that
our friends our family everyone out
there to make sure that these races go
the way that we need uh for the pro
democracy people um so rachel tell us
where they can find you and how they can
find that messaging
yeah i mean you can follow me on twitter
i dish out political strategic advice
all day long
to the universe in hopes that it will be
acted upon uh at rachel bitte copper but
i'm also um i have a forthcoming book
next year from crown and it's called hit
him where it hurts how to save democracy
by beating republicans at their own game
and really excited about that project
well we are we are super excited about
um the the book coming out on how to
smash republicans at all
that always sounds exciting to me so i'm
excited about that thank you rachel for
joining us again sorry about the trouble
yesterday but i'm glad you got to join
us sorry guys boys
i was like
i know
i watched you tried to join like eight
or nine times well i tried i even tried
driving somewhere else but it just
wasn't meant to be well maybe maybe
maybe it was so you could come on today
and we could talk about the trump rules
yeah i was making my my 15 ring to
oregon ducks right show off my ducks
jersey
so go ducks is what you're saying
all
okay bye thank you we'll we'll talk to
you very soon have a good one
oh man well it's great to have rachel
back on the show and texas paul what a
great day we haven't even got we haven't
even we haven't started i know i know
it's just the day it's just the [ __ ]
it's just the [ __ ] and we have you back
today too i know i was busy with the
bunker and stuff
right well i tweeted out i tweeted out i
didn't know if that you know the raid
had something to do with
digging i'll just say this deep state
because deep state started to trend with
these morons yeah i always say all i'll
say is no comment okay like those
classified documents i can't really talk
more than i was just overseeing the
project of building a bunker did you did
you see did you see this morning that uh
hunter biden's laptop was like
uh i don't even have a safe
oh yeah i saw that comment live on fox
news it was just up there and it was
like i do not have a safe
so um let's go through the tweety tweets
and attorney trains because there's a
lot of [ __ ] to get through today and we
only got 30 minutes to do it yesterday i
floated the idea that we go to three
hours without you
i did that on purpose and they love the
idea i'm not sure how you feel about it
but let's do this let's surf the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends let's do
lightning round let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ]
list welcome welcome welcome back to the
tony michaels podcast you have reached
the part of the show where we surfed the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends and
the shitless
roundup game there's a lot of [ __ ] to
round up
holy moly i mean we've got we've got
andrew
andrew yang twinning at number two the
fbi trending at number three makes sense
um it just it just keeps going on and on
and on here andrew cuomo weighs in
because he's under investigation and
doesn't want donald trump under
investigation he's still under
investigation well i mean he is andrew
cuomo i wouldn't put it past him uh
let's go to the andrew yang see what
andrew yang uh no i don't want to see
what andrew you know
nope no thank you [ __ ] you i think i
think if i remember seeing it correctly
he was giving
he was giving his two cents
on uh
on and i'll just read it to you well
here i'll go to it all right all right
he gave his two cents on the whole uh
raid some people don't like the language
raid
like raid because it implies that it was
a you know it'll it'll incite
uh
violence and stuff or like that it was
well and technically legally i mean it's
a legal search warrant right technically
it's not a raid and the reason why
technically it's not a raid it's because
the federal magistrate actually
gave the
uh the legal search warrant his
signature that's by the way
by the way
it was bruce reinhardt
and he was approved or appointed who was
he appointed by can you thank guess
bruce reinhardt this sounds like a
really trumped-up white dude so i'm
gonna guess trump no well i mean it was
by rick scott former florida governor
rick scott
so you had ray appointed by trump
reinhardt appointed by scott
so
i don't need to hear anyone coming in
here
what you're saying is a guy who gave the
go-ahead on this search warrant is a
republican or at least appointed by by a
republican in a in like an alien skin i
mean by bare minimum standards here's
andrew yang's tweet here's his dumb
[ __ ] tweet it seems like this was
authorized by a local judge and a
particular fbi office without buying a
notification of higher level of how do
you know this he does not know this yeah
but literally no one will believe that
or make a distinction it's probably
bureaucrat
really it's just it's political it seems
like legal it seems like what trump was
doing was illegal
so what they were doing
was doing a legal way of law and order
right they were they were issuing a
search warrant that had been that had
been signed off by a republican judge
who was appointed by rick scott
and and sent up or sent down
from fbi director christopher wray who
was appointed by trump so this whole
idea that's like left leaning and it's
attacked by the left and the deep state
and dark brand and that's all [ __ ] that
dude it's a it is everyone that was
involved
are all from the right these are all
people that have power that signed off
and gave the go-ahead people on the
right
speaking of dark brandon kicking ass and
taking names
um he did give a speech as racial
mission on the chips and science act
uh earlier here is uh here's a little
bit of a speech he's holding his glasses
um in his hand
i think he's gonna i think he's gonna
kind of stoke this dark brandon thing uh
it seems like something biden would do
just just these little easter eggs where
he's holding his glasses deal with it
right
deal with it walks away right let's
let's watch last month i awarded steve
jobs
yeah
presidential medal of freedom
posthumously
at every turn of his life he dared to
think differently
embodied that most of american questions
what next
the chips and science act is going to
inspire a whole new generation of
americans to answer that question what
next
right now is bill can tell you nasa has
a mission
going back to the moon then to mars the
sun and beyond capturing
capturing
images of the distant galaxies
we could only once dream existed and we
could never think we could see
so here is uh joe biden dark dark
brandon i'm giving
giving his two cents on uh what this
chips and science act does because gabe
i think i think he's actually
he's downplaying it a bit because this
this act is huge because it's not just
about the advancement of science and
technology which i know you're highly
interested in but it also gives the
ability of the american people to
actually manufacture these things here
as opposed to overseas in china that's
that's really the intent of it is to
start manufacturing these things here
and have american chips as opposed to
and you think like this is just like
infrastructure this will take time to
build up right the reason that china and
other
other countries in southeast asia are
the ones that we go to is because they
literally said
this will be a a
a factory city we will be
building ships you know uh on pcb boards
microprocessors like these will be
things that we will be only focused on
and
uh
america the us has a lot to make up on
right we're decades worth of time that
we're behind
so this is an investment for a future
and it will certainly be one that takes
time because right now if you were to
manufacture chips in the u.s right
fabricate chips you would need to do
them on a very small but expensive scale
versus you go to china and it's a large
scale at a low cost right because they
already have that infrastructure put in
place and we don't have that yet well
and and that's what this act is designed
to do is to help us build that
infrastructure right so we can build a
lot of these things here and create
american jobs and bring some of this
manufacturing of this technology back to
our country and you're right we we so
long for so many decades um
built the infrastructure over there to
build these things you know
inexpensively when maybe we didn't
realize we could build them here and
we're starting to realize that and
america is starting to come back to that
attitude so hopefully this will help uh
areas like detroit and the rust belt in
pennsylvania i think some of those
manufacturing areas that were that were
such the heartbeat of this country when
we used to manufacture steel and cars
and so many things manufactured in that
area of the country now we might be able
to bring it back and you bring up a good
you bring up a good point which is the
auto industry right like this is our
there are two things that i believe are
connected to this one is that
doing the chips act and building
infrastructure to have a manufacturing
for chips
uh will not only one be our like kind of
next
phase of the auto industry right the
chip industry here in the us but also
uh modern day cars they run on ships
right not only computers and tvs but
cars which we are in uh
uh we are certainly not stopping the
production of are things that we need um
and it actually has halted the the
production of vs because we can't get
those chips from overseas because
there's been a shortage because you know
all these things that have happened so
um this will you know it'll be a direct
direct
line into the auto industry but other
industries as well but this could be its
own auto industry kind of uh revolution
if you will well let's see what dark
brandon has to say in closing here well
i tell you what
detroit's making some really hot
vehicles
there's dark brandon there you go
and there you go mention it mention of
the cars that's right like that's super
important i mean i think you're right
that car industry um is i mean because
we are we are an automobile culture in
this country and it is so important and
so vital to our jobs um to have
that ability to to manufacture those
those cars speaking of dark brandon i
want to bring up a um you know we we
joked about it but this morning and i
brought this up they were freaking out
on fox news here they're here they're
they're not understanding what the dark
brandon thing is on fox news watch this
i like that dark brandon rice
yeah that's a that's a really that's a
really good piece of art and now the
dark brandon thing it started with uh
you know these let's go brandon nazis
trying to make it as if you know it's
some kind of nefarious thing and they
were making all these memes and
everyone's like well what's wrong with
joe biden being a complete total badass
and it really backfired them but watch
how fox news
does not understand the internet and how
the internet works watch this this is
hilarious here the dark brandon
reaction after the white house tries to
rebrand the president
cringe taken to a new level
definitely
you're definitely
definitely what's funny about this the
right can't meme well it's what's funny
about this is that she thinks this is
the white house rebranding
joe biden like what are you talking like
it only it it's only worked its way into
mainstream just within the last week or
two right you know into the mainstream
of social media you know who else didn't
understand uh dark brandon oh i can only
imagine
seth seth abramson
seth who seth who abramson oh okay yeah
the one who came after me you know but i
saw i somebody sent me a a thread of his
that i had to uh i had to go on another
account to look at because he blocked me
but
on that thread he goes through and talks
about dark brandon and it wasn't until a
few down does he realize that dark
brandon is actually a meme that was
started on the left thinking that it was
something from like there's there's a
whole misunderstanding of what memes are
and what the humor is behind them and of
course did a
you know a 1900
uh long
diatribe thread yeah of course that he
goes no let's talk about this dark
brandon not understanding what dark
brandon was just well because he because
he heard brandon and he thought it was
like a a dig on the left
which they've been doing the let's go
brandon thing for what a year and a half
now or whatever it was but instead of
instead of you know stopping doing the
research like a journalist he just went
out and started posting about it and
then at that point it was like oh i
gotta
i gotta do this live you know and so
it's uh
i don't know i think i think this uh
dark brain and stuff uh dark garland
because we we uh named our episode today
dark garland and rage trump i just think
it's and with the thumbnail that we had
it's a beautiful thumbnail because it
really it really irritates the [ __ ] out
of them you know what i mean
well yeah of course when you when you
take something that they're like we were
doing it you know because it was
december
2021
is when the let's go brandon
uh that was when that big moment kind of
happened of the guy who said let's go
brandon to biden over the phone there
obviously before that was during nascar
but that was kind of like when it really
took off
but the idea that their their attempt at
messaging was co-opted right remember
it's not only that one but you've also
got the i did that stickers on anything
that is gas related or anything in the
economy right somebody has a negative
thing to say about joe biden it's a
sticker him saying i did that which now
the gas is going down gas goes down
other things are up and doing well and
so it's another thing that they
in the moment they were like we're going
to [ __ ] own them we're going to get
them so good
and what they don't do is one understand
how the economy works
long-term they they are not future
proofing because what they did there was
they thought in the short term and they
said this is good right now but not
realizing also stickers stick and
they're kind of permanent so they stay
on for a while and that other things
that they've said in the past well and
the pictures of the stickers the
pictures of the stickers right they live
forever on the internet yeah they live
forever you're joking about oh man we
got you so good did you though because
if you just would have waited it out a
little bit
you would seem you would see how it kind
of backfired on you and so that's just
it again they do not know how to future
proof
their
um their ideas their negative kind of
attacks against biden or against the
democrats because it ends up you know
reverses and comes back to them it's
kind of like a reverse uno card right it
was like dished out and they're like oh
[ __ ]
you know well we have the national
archives trending as well there's a lot
of stuff trending on this case yeah and
it seems as if the
uh the national archives and the 15
boxes um it's becoming more and more
clear that that was the actual thrust of
this uh search warrant not raid no
everyone but it is a raid it is a search
warrant you know what whatever the hell
you want to call it the point is is that
the national archives and the in the
documents
that the cheeto desk mobster stole from
our white house there are documents um
this is the reason why this happened now
i want to take a look back right because
when when we discovered that there were
you know these boxes of documents
down at mar-a-lago that he had taken a
lot of people like well what the hell
does that mean right like it was kind of
you know swept under the rug no big deal
they actually the national archives went
down there to retrieve these records um
they worked with i think trump staff to
get these records you know all gathered
up back into the boxes and into their
possession
but gabe i really do believe that
that national archive team knew that
there was nefarious stuff going on just
by the records that were taken the stuff
like you said the inventory and the
audits that were done like they're
looking they're going why in the [ __ ]
what the hell he took that that that and
that yeah yeah and i believe that the
department of justice was notified by
the national archives at that point
and i would i would almost suspect i
would almost suspect that if that is the
case and the fbi was onto this they
would want to make sure when the team of
national archives went down to
mar-a-lago that there were some actual
agents that were you knew what they were
looking for beyond
um what those national archives people
were just to make sure that there was no
crime happening on the scene
as they were collecting those boxes
because the national archives aren't law
enforcement they're not they're not part
of the department of justice or law
enforcement right i would imagine there
were some in-beds or some law
enforcement agents yeah again because
these people that came in yesterday
wasn't like a you know a ton of agents
came in
like it was a like a scene out of a
movie
um you know just like busting through
the door or like the meme of the fbi age
is like fbi open up doo doo doo and then
like they bust in the door right uh that
would have been great to see but you
know that wasn't what happened i mean
they had people that were undercover
they had people that were in civilian
clothes
and then you know boom they flipped out
the badge and you know whatever but the
they didn't want anyone to to really
know and again the i uh i think did
rachel say how the secret service was
notified beforehand well they would have
to be because right exactly but like
because because like paul said if if if
if people are rolling down the street in
fbi things the secret service has to
keep that compound secure just like just
like we see some of the radio fodder
from the january 6th they were unsure if
they they didn't know what the hell was
gonna happen some of those secret
service agents they're like i don't know
who i'm gonna have to i'm gonna maybe
die here they were sending you know
their last wishes to their family and
stuff their last love to their family
because they weren't sure with the siege
happening
who was going to come who was going to
be the violent one they because their
duty is to protect whoever they are in
charge right in the area they're in
charge of and the way that the secret
service would be in charge of protecting
donald trump at mar-a-lago like that's
their duty that they are they are held
to an oath to do that so
and that's where it comes in like local
law enforcement and state police just
like when you would have a president go
to a certain um spot for like a a rally
or a meeting or whatever it may be
the state police and the local police
would be in charge of making sure that
not just not just that the secret
service uh consider the president but
they can secure areas as they're moving
him the local police would be in charge
of that so the streets and the roads
leading to palm beach uh in front of
mar-a-lago yeah it is highly likely that
the local law enforcement and the state
police and ron desantis knew about this
we'll never actually probably know that
that is will probably always be sealed
at least for a couple generations here
until we'll know the history of that but
but um it is clear that there is a
possibility that ron desantis knew this
and he was like you know what
i'm just gonna let this happen um and
just stand back and stand by and watch
donald trump get get wasted here um so i
think there's a lot of that that could
that could have went on the other thing
that's trending um is about um it looks
like about this federal judge
is that the one that you were talking
about yeah bruce reinhardt are you
talking about the magistrate um you know
i'm not real sure that's what i'm trying
to find here it's just there's um
um there's
it's just that the the federal judge the
words are trending so i'm not sure
exactly
um let's go to joyce here um she's
always joyce vance always has a
good take we don't know yet what crimes
the fbi had significant evidence of
to convince a federal judge there was
probable cause to search trump's
residence
but the execution of the search warrant
isn't a raid it's uh
um it is judicially overseen process
still unknown the subject of search and
i think what she's saying here because
she's talking about the federal judge
but a little different what she's saying
here is what we were saying earlier
because there is a judge involved
in in executing the search warrant it is
a search warrant not a raid where a raid
would be done by law enforcement by
probable cause
right that that because you would take a
law enforcement agency and that agency
the fbi it would be only take one um
branch of government which would be the
executive branch under the department of
justice to execute a raid whereas they
got a federal magistrate involved
and that is where um this has happened
ted lou is also tweeting here let's see
what he
he has to say um he's tweeting at uh
representative hashbarger here the fbi
director is is a republican
um
representative dana hashberger here the
inconsistent and
partisan application of the law by the
fbi has gone too far here's another
republican yelling and screaming about
the unfairness
the democrats for far too long have used
our government agencies from the fbi to
the irs to target their political
opponents well if the politicians
weren't such [ __ ] criminals the fbi
and the irs wouldn't have to [ __ ]
search them and charge them with crimes
right yes and if you don't raid
yeah it's like don't complain about
oh i'm i'm a victim of this crime oh i'm
being illegally searched or seized or
whatever it is right like don't complain
about this stuff
right the only because if you're doing
it then you're guilty but also like if
you don't
want to be accused of this uh
illegal act then don't do it right if
you don't want to be accused of a crime
then don't commit a crime stop criming
that's a good idea to stop it
it seems pretty kind of straightforward
if you don't want to be considered a
criminal then don't cry don't commit a
crime don't do anything illegal well her
colleague here ted cruz
from california's 36 he responds
to representative hashbarger
the fbi director is a republican
and also have you seen the documents the
law enforcement agency seat at
mar-a-lago or the search warrant the
federal judge approved
no and he's trying to make a point here
what he's trying to say is you people
really don't know what you're talking
about right and really you should err on
the side of i don't know maybe a hundred
fbi agents maybe the department of
justice maybe the federal magistrate
that has seen the evidence maybe you
should err on the side of that until
until we get this but here's the thing
and i and i want people to understand
this and why this is so important in our
country
that you are innocent until proven
guilty and the reason why that is so
important is because the republicans
don't want that
they want you to just like hunter biden
like they want him to be guilty until
proven innocent right he has to prove
his innocence here um but also we have
the court of public opinion which is the
exact opposite you are guilty
until proven innocent right um and that
is what the republicans are trying to do
here they're trying to run rough shot
over your
opinion of what actually could happen
here um he also ted lou also goes on to
say you have no idea what you're talking
about how do you know crimes weren't
committed she doesn't but she she
doesn't care
and
and the reason why she doesn't care is
there's no consequence
of her doing this uh at least not by law
enforcement there could be consequences
from you the voter so uh thanks ted lou
for pointing
out
and you're going to see that a lot right
you're going to see the narrative come
out of ronda santos and the rest of
these people say oh it's an attack from
the left and it's a political you know
uh
political regime of biden
using this you know for his own personal
attack against trump
again
they're talking about
these two people running for president
2024 we haven't even hit the 2022
midterms
and no one has announced that they're
running for president yet so like you
know one is they're projecting their own
fear but two is they're trying to find
an enemy but the enemy is actually
within it is their own party it is
people that are you know republican fbi
director chris wray republican federal
magistrate that signed up on the search
warrant that was appointed
by rick scott right a republican
governor at the time
like this is not left-wing there's not
deep state this is all these are people
who are on the right
who who are part of this that followed
the the rule of law law and order you
know
um and republicans don't like that
well obviously they they don't like the
rule of law especially when it hits them
where it hurts um which is their dear
leader um but but they had to have seen
this coming i mean we watched
the january 6 8 select hearings he
obviously
has um an affinity for criming he
obviously does not give a [ __ ] about
america he does not give a two [ __ ]
about anything but himself
and that's probably what is going to
prove out in these in the search for the
records here
um but i do want to take a side note
here because
we lost a bit of news yesterday
right and that bit of news was in the
beginning of the day and it was kind of
a fire hose
at the very beginning
do you remember because i i think i even
text you i said you know what last week
there was a [ __ ] ton of news last week
so much news we could barely keep up but
yesterday morning there was almost as
much news just in yesterday morning
because we had paul manafort admitting
yeah
admitting that he turned over
the campaign numbers and the campaign
information to the russian spies um we
and we had several other bits of news
but the one piece of news that got lost
was the pictures of the notes in trump's
toilet yeah and i got breezed over i
actually covered it yesterday but it
kind of got breezed over yeah i'm really
gonna forget about that do you think
that has anything to do
with because there's records in the
bottom of a toilet and of course elise
stefanik came up because it was obvious
that her last name was on these notes
right um what do you make of that do you
think that was kind of a floating of
what was gonna happen in the later i
mean it was certainly it was certainly
floating that's for sure but it's
the photos i mean i have a i have a much
bigger issue with what's happening
however you have paul manafort who gets
a pardon so he's like cool i am free of
all these crimes i don't have to worry
about it i can now write about it
and he's taken the same
same tactic that people like you know
stephanie grisham
uh uh you you've got people who are you
know maggie haberman who again shared
these photos of her book right to be
like oh look there were photos in the
toilet some people saying how it was
staged
but it's much it's a it's part of a
bigger problem which is these people
who are not willing
to
to to talk about the crime that is being
committed at that time they're not
willing to come forward and say hey yo i
saw this guy eating documents i saw him
flushing [ __ ] down the toilet or like
flushing documents down the toilet in
addition to [ __ ]
um you know i i saw
him do this right he lit this on fire i
was a part of the team that was in
charge of doing xyz that was illegal
right like these people are coming
forward after the fact
and
it's
it's all for profit right if these
people were really you know country over
party
then they would have come forward
initially but right now it's all you
know how do i make the most money for
releasing the juiciest gossip of the
trump administration that was a [ __ ]
show you know
and it is i mean it was crazy to get
these things that were kind of in the
same kind of sphere or theme but it's
it's tiring it's exhausting to see these
people do that they're like got a new
memoir got a new book i'm going to talk
about these things that i experienced
that i wasn't willing to tell the
american public or people about how we
have this danger this fear while the
person was actually in office that
person being trump well here's another
example of that of news that will get
swept underneath the rug because of this
raid is john kelly
disclosed that trump wanted uh nazi
style generals which right then john
kelly kind of had to explain to trump
he's like well d you know that like
in the 1940s as the as nazi germany kind
of winded down the generals were the
ones trying to kill him yeah to get rid
of him because they did i mean that's
what you want you know right so he
didn't he doesn't really understand
history didn't they the other the other
little bit of news was was general milly
uh general millie's little undelivered
uh resignation letter where he basically
called him a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and
the worst thing that's ever happened to
the country in so many words i forget
the exact quote but general milly was
not did not said it was something that
was like a great and dangerous something
it was something the most the most
dangerous threat to our to my country
exactly something along those lines what
he was basically telling trump is you
you are a danger to my country and i can
no longer stay under my oath and serve
you which we know millie did and he did
kind of you know obviously if that right
that resignation level was never sent he
did it not of his um of what he wanted
to do but what he felt like he had to do
maybe um to save our country but but
where like you said where was that
information
i mean like if these people really are
if these people one are true patriots to
believe country over party and three
believe that you know we should live
within this democracy and we should make
sure that we are a strong and powerful
nation
why are they letting these things happen
i mean we live in a capitalistic society
right we have we have been taught in in
kind of indoctrination on this idea that
you have to make money as much as
possible and it's profit over people and
that is what has happened with all these
people whether it's me whether it's
manafort whether it's haberman whether
it's grisham or anyone else you know ban
whoever might be that was it that was
involved in the in this administration
they all knew it to some extent of these
their own personal
uh experiences and were unwilling like
if there is not especially like if you
look at a group of people that are like
oh i know this person is a problem and
we may not agree on the same uh side of
the political spectrum right if i'm a
reporter or if i'm part of the
administration or whatever it might be
the fact that every one of them looked
at it and said
i can make more money if i sell it in a
book i think tells you a big thing about
our own society
uh that it's a it's it is a problem and
right now we are experiencing the
negative aspects you know whether it's
our own economy or it's the way in which
we structure our society amongst people
but also
these
what should not be secrets right
that's that's kind of it's gonna it's
gonna happen again and again and again
uh because that is how we've been kind
of taught to go about it which is gotta
make money gotta look out for number one
um i can't release all the secrets
because if i do then i won't be able to
make that profit right and it's it is
sad to see it is disgusting well we have
to hold all these people accountable and
the way we do that is gauging our
democracy like we talked so many times
every day every single weekday actually
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific for two full hours
on youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page we do not [ __ ] around here
folks we are on the air every single day
pounding the drum of democracy trying to
trying to give you a way to look through
the lens of democracy to try to
politicize this at every turn that's
right i said it we should politicize
this um we should make politics about
that that is the only way that we are
going to make sure that pro-democracy
control the government as opposed to
some of these fascists that that want to
hail the hungarian hitler and mango
mussolini jesus over the weekend and
then make excuses excuses as the fbi the
department of justice the federal judge
says oh we think this guy's coming to
crimes we need to go find out we need to
go find the crimes he committed and then
make excuses and want to and then accuse
accuse pro-democracy people of doing the
exact same thing that they want to do
and then they say all in the same breath
just elect us and we'll do those things
we'll get vengeance on those people
we'll have a personal vendetta against
them we'll do the exact hear what you
just said right we'll do the exact
things that we're saying are un-american
and vile to them that we say it's doing
which there's no evidence that that is
happening right so so stick around uh
don't
don't um
leave
this channel you have to stay on this
channel you have to subscribe go watch i
know we have a ton of new listeners
today go watch our our past episodes um
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
go over to twitter follow us at the tony
michaels podcast because we we have
polls we tweet this stuff and also
download every single episode on apple
spotify google make sure to leave us a
good review and if you would i know a
lot of people like to watch the show
live and like to watch it here on
youtube but if you would if you have a
favorite directory that you listen to
apple spotify google
go ahead and download our episodes maybe
just listen to the first i don't know 20
30 minutes of it in like
two times the speed
just to make sure that we're getting the
downloads that we deserve over there
help us out we appreciate all the
audience joining us all the new audience
that joined us today uh i want to thank
texas paul and rachel dr rachel
biddikoffer for coming on the show and
giving us a breakdown not just not just
of uh what their funny thoughts are of
the raid but the actual politics and the
seriousness of it and gabe i'm glad
you're back i'm glad you're with you me
too tomorrow well i'm gonna post it
later today but tomorrow we can play uh
i got a copy of some footage from this
uh legal search warrant
right aka rape uh of mar-a-lago trump's
home so i'm just saying look be on the
lookout it's coming out today i will
release it but from what i've seen it is
pretty crazy well everyone get daniel
dale on the horn so that he can factor
it is fact check it as soon as it drops
because we don't want anything slipping
through the cracks here can't have
anyone freaking out
no we don't we don't want people to
think this thing is uh is fake or
anything everyone please subscribe to
the channel here go download the
episodes every single weekday follow us
at the tonymichaelspod on twitter keep
up to date stay up to speed keep your
outrage strategic
stay pissed go [ __ ] vote engage in
your democracy politicize these fascists
because it is the only way that we save
our democracy until tomorrow noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific right
here on youtube twitter twitch
and simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page surfs
up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules no boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking